so did anything crazy happen this
weekend at skank Fest or uh through two
weeks ago sorry two weeks ago no I
wasn't drinking I took the month off oh
yeah oh yeah that's right yeah
um so it's a it's the wrong time to do
it this is a drinking town and a
drinking Festival they even walk through
the hallways at the [ __ ] wherever
they're putting me up it's like God damn
it
wow so during September October if you
just slip and you're like I can't do it
you break down and have a drink is
anyone gonna know so there was one
moment where it was No No One's Gonna
Know It's Just honor you know it's just
like you know you have honor
it's a weird set of Honor
um yeah well you know when you lose a
bet when you got to do some [ __ ] for
Jackass or whatever like you just have
to do it that's right the deal
I'm not going to but it's like that's
lame you know it's the funniest thing
about sober October is that when it
comes up yeah
like my first thought like I was like I
was shipping for a whole month and I
think [ __ ] man that's gnarly you know I
like this and then I'm like oh yeah like
I'm sober all the time yeah like it
makes me uncomfortable like sober
performance so it'll be around drunk
yeah even though because you're thinking
of old Steve yeah
it's weird and it continues to happen
you don't mess with the whoop strap at
all
I no I did once it was cool but we have
to do this polar [ __ ] whatever they
chose to like yeah we do 500 uh calories
a day you're gonna burn which I also
hate and 100 push-ups where I physically
cannot do I'm like maxed out at five on
day one I was like hey guys I think I'm
in trouble here by the end of the month
like I did yeah I'm getting better but
like uh so anyway I was doing Rogue
because I was hanging out with Rogan he
goes I just interviewed Roger Waters
like two days ago I was like that's so
[ __ ] badass and uh I saw him once on
acid in Rhode Island actually uh and it
was such a [ __ ] good concert after
they opened for Great White after they
opened great ride they really took off
because gray white was no longer a
threat to the dominance of Rhode Island
um and uh you guys making me in it like
[ __ ] well you know Roger wants to do
pyrotechnics so um these are into lasers
so he was like I got tickets to a show
tomorrow or tonight and I'm like oh I
can't go I gotta flight back and he's
like well I have a [ __ ] seven hundred
thousand billion dollars so like I'll
just change your flight for you and I'm
like oh well I have no Hotel it's like
the same same and I'm like no I gotta
get home it's like aren't you account
I'm like yep I gotta stay so I'm gonna
see Roger Waters but I'm sober and I'm
like no it's disrespectful
to go see Roger Waters sober it's
disrespectful and so I asked the other
guys and I was like is there something I
could do to make up for this
I just want to take one tab of acid
I won't couple it with alcohol and weed
I'll be strong
and they were like add a hundred sit-ups
a day to like your [ __ ] regimen and
you can and I view it as a [ __ ]
religious
religious like uh what did like uh you
know you're allowed to do something for
yeah holy Scrolls
what if the acid like was wasn't great
it'd be disappointing yeah it was
stronger than I thought it would be dude
it was stronger than I thought of it the
guy got I got it and it was like he was
like I just dip this right now so like
dry it out so I'm like holding in the
car over there I'm holding it open this
bag and open in the air conditioner vent
of a [ __ ] car just like trying to dry
it out I was with Hinchcliffe too and I
was like uh and the only other person
that took it Rogan was like I wanna
[ __ ] touch that street ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
you and I'm like you're wrong
um and the only person that took it the
only one that was a man was Tony
hinchcliffe's uh girlfriend she was
saying it's gonna [ __ ] post out and
we had a blast it was so [ __ ] strong
there's an intermission we went
backstage and all of a sudden it's like
regular people and we're like nah we
shouldn't be here for this so I went
back up and they were like Rogan and all
his bodyguards like hey man we're
leaving like before the last song this
is like a cavalcade to get us out you
got to be on that thing and I was like
I'm not gonna I'm out gonna be I mean
I'm crying in the [ __ ] in this in the
crowd next to some 80 year old lady ball
it crying oh what a good [ __ ] show
you guys gotta go see Roger Waters on
acid yeah wouldn't have been a good show
and not on acid sure yeah absolutely
bench cliff and Rogan had a good time
yeah I feel like the acid in the 90s was
a lot stronger than the acid they're
making now is that not true definitely
can't be true because people are like
not dosing and [ __ ] going on Hikes
now no micro dose but like I don't know
about micro dosing in the 90s they just
took a [ __ ] hit acid like a man but
they're like seeing [ __ ] things
dripping off
like now they're like doing yoga on acid
it's like how how is that possible do I
have that wrong
I I tripped balls in the 90s yeah can
you imagine tripping balls now I think
it was unregulated then so you didn't
know you might get some you might get
the equivalent of like four hits of acid
I'm pretty sure the acid is still not
regulated good point Street ass yeah
yeah but they do that they have like a
number of them 200 somethings and I'm
like yeah but this was not that but
who's saying that who's saying it
exactly you're just taking somebody's
word for it I was in a festival we had
Bonnaroo got canceled with an RV like
this and we were loading up our [ __ ]
RV with groceries for Bonnaroo and I got
a call like it ain't happening and it
wasn't covid it was it was raining and I
was like it's nice out like it rang for
the last six days the water's up to
their knees it's done it's done they're
not like delaying it it's over
I'm like [ __ ] and so we found this like
meth Festival I call it in like Western
Georgia like we still got some RV spots
and I'm like I'm going to that so we
just went there
we're buying drugs and this